le patriarche de moscou est arrivé à
cuba aujourd'hui le monde chrétien va
assister demain à un événement on peut
lire dans ce cas-ci historique le pape
françois le chef de l'église catholique
de rome va rencontrer kirill le chef de
l'église orthodoxe russe cela ne s'était
jamais vu en milan depuis le grand
schisme en fait entre les chrétiens de
l'occident et ceux de lorient
alors alain crevier qu'est ce que
signifie cette rencontre pourquoi c'est
si important d'abord faute est une
histoire honnêtement ça peut paraître
banal mais c'est une histoire absolument
fascinant ça se passe donc en 1054 la
famille chrétienne la grande famille
chrétienne va connaître tout une rupture
une rupture dont on parle encore
aujourd'hui est au coeur de cette
rupture là il y à des débats pointue des
débats théologiques dont vous ne voulez
pas que je vous parle
mais il ya aussi de la politique les
orthodoxes particulièrement en russie et
ailleurs dans le monde mais en russie on
dit on trouve que le pape a tendance
déjà à l'époque à vouloir occuper tout
le territoire
mais souvenez vous allez pas parler de
l'église s'était parlé dans pire c'était
parler d'armé et on parlait de guerre de
pouvoir ce n'est pas banal à l'époque
donc pas banal mais pourquoi maintenant
pourquoi ce réchauffement là vous savez
que ça fait des décennies que j'emporte
par exemple jean paul ii aurait vendu
ses souliers et sa copine pour pouvoir
marcher à moscou il rêvait de la grande
réunification de la famille entre les
orthodoxes et les catholiques il a tout
fait il a même offert aux orthodoxes il
leur a dit si c'est la papauté qui vous
fait problème
ben ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on
s'assoit et qu'on redéfinisse les règles
de la papauté
ça n'a pas fonctionné à la place qu'on
sait c'est que depuis deux ans
top secret il ya des négociations entre
moscou et rome top secret parce qu'on
sait bien que les franges
traditionalistes n'aime pas du tout
l'idée de cette rencontre on pourrait
torpiller l'idée le projet alors top
secret ça va et maintenant les deux
hommes se trouve par hasard me
direz-vous en amérique du sud
c'est qui qui leur offre un territoire
l'hospitalité c'est castro le nouvel ami
de françois et c'est quand même céline
tout un paradoxe parce que vous avez un
pays a t qui ouvre les portes aux deux
grands frères de la chrétienté pour une
potentielle réconciliation éventuelle
atteinte et rennes
être on peut dire entre même si milan
laissé par le pape et le patriarche ont
à coeur au moins une grande cause
commune qui occupent l'actualité en ce
moment oui vous savez on parle souvent
de la terre sainte
on a l'impression où vous et moi et
combien d'autres que la terre sainte
c'est aussi chrétien ces catholiques
mais ces chrétiens or il n'en est plus
rien la terre sainte est en train de se
vider de ses chrétiens les chrétiens
sont pourchassés ils sont en exil ils
ont pris la route de l'exil c'est la
détresse
or voilà que les deux les deux grands
patrons de ces églises se réunissent
demain je serais très étonné dans le
communiqué de presse qui payera bhl qui
aboutira à quelque part en milieu de
journée
je serais très étonnée qu'on ne parle
pas du sort des chrétiens il ya autant
d'orthodoxie que de catholiques dans cet
univers-là qui est en perdition pour les
catholiques et les orthodoxes
alain crevier toujours un plaisir merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir pensé à moi
merci